so all the work Akaka is not quite ripe
for harvest just yet I kind of show you
that my subscribe button certainly is
which you should immediately take
advantage of resulting in regular Jojo
contents being uploaded straight until
YouTube feed I mean yeah it's unlikely
to cure your up disease but it will cure
a tiny bit of your boredom maybe do it
anyway it couldn't hurt much hello and
welcome to the new world to view your
source for everything anime and manga
and today I present to you what I would
call some very risky content with a
review of chapter 95 of Jojo Liang risky
because Jojo Leon isn't already failing
each sector of in each series and
reviews typically do not do very well in
this channel at the best of times but
we're going to give this a go regardless
and to begin I really do have to say
that I am very unsteady on the subject
of reading monthly manga in general a
month to me feels like just enough time
to have forgotten about the intricacies
of anything going on in series but with
that in mind
chapter 95 was a pretty solid experience
quite probably due to the fact that we
are rapidly reaching the height of drama
in part 8 and there's quite a bit to
digest in this chapter much more so than
your average one and first and foremost
rest in peace for Dad so given how
recently I got into pod 8 I'm still not
sure how I feel about nori ski in
general but that goes for most of the
cost of Georg early on because they are
all such morally ambiguous figures I
will say that it was still pretty
heartbreaking to watch norisse case
demise though however it may have been
potentially slightly undercut by the
fact that we all knew it was coming
thanks to the flash-forward all those
chapters ago still this was a pretty
brutal way to go out with job
inactivating speaking to do the deed I
mean death by heatstroke is just not
Envia bull in any way definitely not my
choice to leave this world although at
least it was fairly quick so there is
that but it certainly is a shame because
norisse gay was quite the character
someone who I said I was never quite
sure if I was on board with or not and
that feeling remains right up until the
end here because even in his final
moments he seemed like he was at very
least prepared to let Yasu who died if
that was indeed the best course of
action for the family which you know
pretty damn cold but completely within
the bounds of the character that we've
been presented with thus far in Jojo
Leon in the end though Norris case moral
compasses tuned for us with him
admitting that yeah perhaps he was being
old-fashioned and maybe he could have
come to a more modern way of thinking in
regards to fruit vending management
which is a sentence I never thought I'd
say in my life however when it comes to
his family
Norris key would not veer away from the
path that he believed to be correct
which is a nice show
of semi nobility here but of course
jobbing as being just as stubborn as his
father believing that his way forward is
the only option even if it means killing
said father and you know what it's
starting to feel and all for like job in
is going to be the big band of part
eight I mean yes there are still are the
candidates one of which I'll be
discussing later in this review but job
in has very much crossed a line at this
stage that he can't really return from
murdering your father for the sake of
your beliefs is a pretty big villainous
maneuver but I do appreciate how it was
conducted because just as I wasn't sure
how to feel about Norris gay I'm still
also quite conflicted about jobbing
because he is a man who truly believes
that his actions are all in the service
of the betterment of the world or well
not the world but for the good of his
family and not just his son either
because if this was all about Tsurugi
then there's always the option to a fat
norisse case sacrifice himself for
sorties sake but you know if you're
gonna kill your father anyway at least
save your son in the process so this is
clearly bigger than that well perhaps
it's smaller and much more petty with
job and wanting to be the person to save
his son rather than having his father do
it
either way that right there is a super
strong and compelling characterization
of the villain and it probably works
particularly well with the scale of the
story that has been set up in Jojo Leon
it's another pot for style affair well
we've narrowed down our focus and thus
the final antagonist doesn't have to be
some sort of big world ending a world
reshaping threat like a Buchi or a
Valentine or a deer and furthermore at
this point I feel like jawbone is
probably the only character who can helm
this series and provide any sense of
emotional resonance from a climactic
conflict the only exception to this that
I could see is if it turned out that
alternate universe Keira had been the
true villain all along yes you know he
is a doctor and these days we are
extraordinarily wary of doctors injured
early on anyway
but thus in a weird way it would make
out Jojo both the protagonist and
antagonist of the series which would be
an interesting turn but at the moment
I'm still looking pretty hard at jobbing
although as of yet his Stan doesn't have
the trademark overpowered angle that is
present in every primary antagonist
since towns were introduced still
there's certainly time to evolve
speaking into some sort of fitting
beastly existence of course at the
moment that kind of power is very
present in our head doctor Satoru a
kethu who honestly remains one of the
most intriguing figures that I think
I've ever encountered in a giorgo series
there's just something so profoundly
sinister about a being who brings
misfortune and calamity to you simply by
doing absolutely nothing
except being present his stand ability
really does sound like some sort of
creepypasta you know a legend about a
a man in black and if you so much as see
him then it is more than likely going to
be an indicator of your imminent death
via some sort of bizarre natural force
and then people point out well if
everyone who sees him dies then how do
we know the legend and that's the cycle
of weirdness perpetuates but I'm really
looking forward to discovering how we're
going to deal with him though because he
gives me the same sort of vibes that I
recall having during the Bohemian
Rhapsody arc of part 6 that sort of okay
Archie has done it this stand is just
far far too powerful to ever be defeated
and then the solution ends up being
something so simple it's just kind of
hilarious but we also have the title of
a new arc with this chapter which is
endless calamity part 1 which I imagine
is referring to us placing a renewed
focus on sort order which is the full
stop in regards to the chapter as well
it ends with meets about drawing
attention to the fact that all of this
misfortune being heaped onto the family
is likely a result of Satori's attack so
that's one reason I would say that he
isn't going to be our final enemy
because we appear to have entered an arc
strictly geared towards defeating him
which would still leave job ins
conclusion to come afterwards unless the
threads are somehow cleverly tied
together which you know it's always a
possibility but to me it feels like
joven and Soto need their own separate
arcs to explore and resolve those
characters well I'm still semi focused
on stands though I did want to mention
that it was really nice to see King
nothing again it didn't get a mention in
my joke Jolie on review but this stand
has to be one of my favorite designs and
it's so fascinating to view in action
with all the puzzle pieces and
everything but to me their King nothing
felt like quite and under you stand in
part eight but you know that's probably
purely because I wanted to see more of
it again come to think of it we really
have not seen this stand in an awfully
long time have we I mean I remember it
like it was yesterday but King nothing
was one of those very early game
existences in Jojo Leon and I can't
actually remember if it was used in the
middling chapters and it certainly has
not been invoked before now in the end
times
so with that in mind this chapter I
guess provide a king nothing with a nice
little send-off after promptly ignoring
it for the majority of the series so
King nothing I salute you and your
brilliant design but Pandey really does
have a lot of really unique cool stands
because they also quite like Paisley
Park with its app map texture finish and
such you kind of like King nothing I
just appreciate its presence
artistically in whatever panel it
appears in because it would take some
real effort to put to page and there are
some great moments in this chapter where
Paisley Park appears with Yasuo and the
stand is beautifully reflecting the
anguish of its user or at the very least
as best as an artificial humanoid map
thing can do
so it was nice to know that both it and
yeah so who lived to fight another day
or another hour maybe another minute
really I mean she's still in gran danger
but still it's a sigh of relief because
there was a genuine sense of dread i hat
off to chapter 94 that yeah the entire
family would just let her drown in a
toilet perhaps even Joshua well there
speaking of Joshua he would appear to
have committed inaction in this chapter
that dare I say I appreciated that was
very difficult to say and it's not
explicitly stated but the way the
visuals play out clearly implied that
Joshua is the one who kicked the phone
over to the power point and allowed
Paisley Park to escape and yeah it makes
sense because he's pretty wildly whipped
for you so her but as a result this is
probably the first time that I've
experienced Joshua on a page and not
hated every second I saw of him and to
be clear he's still thoroughly disliked
him I think his design is awful his
comedy is a bit off for me anyway
and there is just so little that is
redeeming about him in any way shape or
form and even in his focus story which
was theoretically supposed to get me on
board with him as character even that by
the end he still turned out to be dick
and really the entire situation could
have been resolved by simply not being a
dick and not stealing them dude's wallet
in the first place but I'm going on a
bit of a Joshua rant now so I should
probably stop before I mention him
wanting to suck on his mother's breasts
but oh well I guess I've mentioned it
down however I will admit that I was
pretty shockingly funny in any case in
the antia we've taken some pretty big
steps towards our teaser flash-forward
in which we saw Tsurugi would know his
body and after mentioning that part in
the Jojo Lian review I was given some
Theory speculating that no that was a
noise gay and it was actually part of
Sookie's Paper Moon King stand somehow
but that very much looks to not to be
the case after this chapter the question
does become there now is Tsurugi going
to reach that point given that his body
seems to have been taken over by the
rock disease and also the fact that in
the flash-forward we saw the whole
family acting fairly normal and the best
explanation i've seen in regards to that
is that their memories will likely be
removed by di'ja in california king bed
but even then I'm still not quite sure
how that results in Tsurugi being saved
or at least temporarily saved from the
raging rock disease unless maybe someone
else makes a sacrifice for him before
the harvest for some sort of reason like
Carter maybe Robert Carter I sure didn't
until I check the Jojo Leon page of the
Jojo wiki for this video but she was
another one of those candidates for
primary antagonist I imagine that she
was brought into the story for a reason
so you know Suri G's condition
we can't wait for the harvest to be
completed and someone is going to need
to act and Kaito is a pretty prime
candidate for that although there really
could be any number of other
explanations because one thing I've
learnt in this whole Georgia business is
that I can never really predict the kind
of craziness that our key is capable of
generating I guess all I can say is that
I am anxiously awaiting no ever nearing
conclusion but yeah all in all Jo Jo
Leon chapter 95 was honestly a much
better experience than I was expecting
it to be while I was reading part 7 in
part 8 I'd often have this sort of wow I
don't know if I'd be able to handle this
being able to spread out over the course
of you know close to a decade but I
never should have doubted that because I
read manga weekly and most of it is a
satisfying spread-out experience but
mostly I'm just an impatient prick and a
month is an awfully long time especially
when you need to hop right back into the
complexities of endgame - Jo Leon
because by then Olive shifted focus to
another series but I will say that this
little injection of Jo Jo very much hit
the spot and reminded me of just how
much I enjoyed reading what there was a
part a dim bulb as well as setting me up
for a promising future experience over
what the next year maybe two because bad
actually cannot last too much longer
than that but what do you guys think
please do let me know in the comments
below or even join my disco server and
if you're keen for some more Giorgio's
content and please do check out some of
my other videos we'll even subscribe to
a channel for regular Jo Jo Wanda
delivered straight to your YouTube feed
but for now this has been the new old
review and I'll see you next time